à partir de la date de samedi 16 dernier
j'ai été suspendu de mon activité
professionnelle
car je ne pouvais pas être vaccinés
[Musique]
j'ai obtenu une dérogation à
l'obligation vaccinale
j'ai un dossier médical qui en est fait
contre indique la vaccination j'ai
rencontré plusieurs médecins qui se sont
opposés à la vaccination
[Musique]
j'ai attester sur l'honneur mais
difficulté mes problèmes de santé je
m'engage et je m'engage à poursuivre mon
activité professionnelle en conservant
les gestes barrière en faisant tester
tous les trois jours s'il le faut là
n'est pas le souci c'est à dire que
j'aimerais avoir une reconnaissance de
cette difficulté de santé qui ne
rentrent pas en fait dans les cases je
peux comprendre que pour eux ce soir une
situation inédite compliqué à gérer mais
je je ne peux prendre là là le risque
d'être vacciné et j'estime avoir le
droit de poursuivre mon activité
professionnelle librement